si on veut augmenter les bas salaires et
je pense qu'il faut effectivement
augmenter les bas salaires qui a un vrai
problème sur l'augmentation quant à
l'augmentation des bas salaires il faut
aller jusqu'au bout de la logique est
dire si on ne veut pas détruire la
compétitivité de l'économie française il
faudra déprécier la monnaie
la question centrale du pouvoir d'achat
d'ores et déjà très omniprésent dans la
campagne présidentielle parmi les pistes
proposées par certains candidats
déclarés ou non l'augmentation des
salaires ce matin à la maire de paris
anne hidalgo a affirmé vouloir augmenter
le smic de 10 à 15% de son côté jean luc
mélenchon a réaffirmé qu'il voulait
remonter ce même smic à 1400 euros nets
ce qui selon lui entraînerait
mécaniquement la hausse des autres aux
salaires alors à six mois de la
présidentielle la surenchère n'en finit
donc plus la hausse du smic à gauche
mais aussi la baisse de la fiscalité à
droite le gouvernement affirme pourtant
que le niveau de vie des ménages a
progressé depuis l'arrivée d'emmanuel
écran alors qu'ils vivraient faudra-t-il
passer par cette fameuse hausse des
salaires notamment des plus bas le
peut-on vraiment on en parle tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
dans son édito échos
bonsoir jacques a tout d'abord c'est
pourquoi pas ton autant des salaires en
ce moment il ya plusieurs raisons tout
d'abord effectivement nous connaissons
une vague d'inflation même si elle est
transitoire elle pèse sur les ménages
elle pèse sur le revenu des ménages
après une deuxième raison c'est que avec
la crise on s'est aperçu que certains
revenus les revenus les plus élevés les
profits les profits des actionnaires
avaient très fortement augmenté alors ça
pose un petit problème et puis un bain
si vous voulez ya quand même la
troisième raison c'est que le
gouvernement dépense sans compter c'est
la politique du chéquier sortie adoptée
par emmanuel macron bon tout ceci mais
d'une certaine manière la question des
salaires du pouvoir d'achat sur la table
au premier plan mais il faut savoir que
ce n'est pas propre simplement à la
france on a des problèmes identiques
dans de très nombreux pays développés en
particulier aux états unis où on assiste
actuellement depuis la fin du mois de
septembre à une vague de grèves dont
justement dans les milieux qui sont les
moins payés chez les travailleurs qui
sont le moins payé alors jacques coeur
répond à cela le gouvernement vous
l'avez dit jean castex a répondu en
disant non le pouvoir d'achat a plus
augmenté sous emmanuel macron qu'ils
avaient augmenté sous ses prédécesseurs
ce soit nicolas sarkozy ou françois à
lourdes alors jean castex s'est fondée
si vous voulez pour cette déclaration
sur un rapport du sénat si on utilise le
rapport que l'os et dès que le fc e
pardon le fc eux vient de publier bien
on vous effectivement on peut le voir là
l'écran que ces deux là il en cas c'est
que ça fondamentalement raison seulement
il faut à ce moment-là remarqué trois
choses premièrement c'est un rattrapage
ce qui se passe sous emmanuel macron le
pouvoir d'achat avait fortement baissé
sous nicolas sarkozy conséquence de la
politique de monsieur françois fillon
ils avaient stagné il n'avait repris que
très lentement sous françois hollande et
la reprise avec emmanuel macron ne fait
que corriger d'une certaine manière ce
qui s'était passé antérieur ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point là on
raisonne en moyenne or il faut savoir
que on peut avoir des chiffres moyens
qui augmente forte et des chiffres pour
les deux premiers déciles c'est à dire
les 20% dès gens qui sont le moins bien
payé qui stagne voix qui régresse ça
c'est un deuxième problème et puis un
troisième problème qui n'est pas pris en
compte dans ce type de graphique c'est
le fait que les dépenses contraintes les
dépenses qu'on est obligé de toutes les
manières de payer à la fin du mois et
bien la part de ces dépenses contraintes
a augmenté depuis une quinzaine d'années
alors quand vous dites que la différence
est importante entre les évolutions sont
les plus pauvres et les plus riches
à quoi vous pensez précisément
lien c'est un calcul que l'insee a fait
et l'insee montrent d'ailleurs que de ce
point de vue là les pauvres subissent
plus l'inflation que les riches alors ya
plusieurs raisons à cela le fait que la
part par exemple de l'énergie dans le
logement du logement la part aussi de la
nourriture est beaucoup plus élevé dans
les ménages les plus pauvres qu'elle ne
l'est dans les ménages les plus riches
qui eux le vent peuvent par exemple plus
consommée en matière si vous voulez de
divertissement en hôtel en restaurant
qui sont des postes ou d'une certaine
manière il ya eu moins d'augmentation
alors c'est important on vérifie que sur
une dizaine d'années l'écart peut-être
de 15% entre les deux catégories et
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui pèse
d'autant plus sur la perception de
l'inflation que ressentent les français
les plus pauvres les français les plus
modestes alors est ce que ces
différences sont uniquement dû à la
consommation dont vous venez de nous
parler non la consommation joue un rôle
extrêmement important mais il ya aussi
l'évolution des revenus et je reviens là
à ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure à
propos de la déclaration de monsieur
jean castex vous pouvez très bien vous
laisser pas du tout contradictoire vous
pouvez très bien avoir
les 10% ou les 20% des revenus les plus
élevés qui voient leurs revenus monter
fortement voire très fortement et les
revenus des 10 ou 20% les plus modestes
qui stagne globalement la moyenne va
continuer à monter mais
ça ne va pas concerner d'une certaine
manière les revenus qui sont en bas de
l'échelle alors c'est important parce
que si vous voulez c'est une erreur qui
est commise assez classiquement par les
politiques est ce que c'est une erreur
où est-ce qu'ils le font volontairement
ça c'est un autre problème mais c'est le
fait de parler d'une moyenne 100
immédiatement données quels sont les
critères de dispersion autour de la
moyenne et c'est bien le problème en
france c'est que la dispersion entre les
plus hauts et les plus faibles est
aujourd'hui extrêmement ouvert alors
ceux qui veulent une hausse du smic est
ce qu'ils ont quelque part raison
pendant que nos enfants oui
fondamentalement si vous voulez en
apparence vous prenez que ce soit le
discours d' anne hidalgo le discours de
jean luc mélenchon le discours de
monsieur fabien roussel lui parle plutôt
d'une augmentation du smic brut que du
smic net mais ça ça revient un peu de
choses aux mains à peu de choses près au
même eh bien ils ont raison mais ils ont
raison malheureusement qu'en apparence
alors jacques pourquoi nous en apparence
évidemment avec laquelle oui et oui si
vous voulez il ya deux problèmes qui se
pose immédiatement
premier problème c'est que on ne peut
pas toucher cosmique et ça c'est un
point important parce que jean luc
mélenchon l'a admis il a dit
effectivement si on augmente le smic par
exemple de 15% et bien il y aura de
toutes les manières une augmentation de
l'ensemble des bas salaires mais c'est
quelque chose dont ne parle ni madame
hidalgo ni monsieur fabien roussel alors
qu'est ce que ça va représenter cet
autre il ya un calcul assez simple
l'étalement d'une hausse globale si vous
voulez sur ce qui est inférieur à la
médiane c'est à dire les 50 % les moins
bien payés des français et bien ça
pourrait représenter sur un an 17
milliards d'euros soit à peu de choses
près entre 0 7 et 0 8% du pipe ce n'est
pas du tout négligeable la deuxième le
deuxième point qui n'est jamais évoquée
c'est que ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on parle en france d'une forte
augmentation du smic
la dernière fois qu'il ya une très forte
augmentation du smic c'est en 1968 ça a
été évidemment les accords de grenelle
bon qu'est ce qui s'est passé est bien
pour maintenir la compétitivité de
l'économie française le gouvernement a
dû fortement dépréciés le franc a dû
faire une dévaluation l'année suivant ça
s'est bien passé la dévaluation était
extrêmement bien maîtrisé mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas le faire
puisqu'on est dans l'euro et donc c'est
un problème si vous voulez on dit il
faut faire une espèce de rattrape at sur
les bas salaires je suis entièrement
d'accord avec eux mais ils ne disent pas
quelle est d'une certaine manière
l'implication de ce rattrapage c'est la
nécessité de déprécier fortement la
monnaie donc ça veut dire que dans un
sens vous donner raison à eric zemmour
qui lui est contre cette augmentation
si vous voulez monsieur eric zemmour est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement logique il
défend en réalité ce qui est une version
un petit peu radicaliser de la politique
que proposait à la dernière élection
présidentielle françois fillon cette
même politique dont on a vu que quand
elle a été appliquée sous nicolas
sarkozy elle avait d'ailleurs entraîné
une baisse importante des revenus moi je
me contente de dire une chose si on veut
augmenter les bas salaires et je pense
qu'il faut effectivement augmenter les
bas salaires qui a un vrai problème sur
l'augmentation quant à l'augmentation
des bas salaires il faut aller jusqu'au
bout de la logique est dire si on ne
veut pas détruire la compétitivité de
l'économie française il faudra déprécier
la monnaie alors donc vous pensez que la
question du pouvoir d'achat va en
réalité faire un stagiaire celle de
l'euro et oui et oui et je pense que je
dois dire que c'est quelque chose qui
est assez caractéristique de l'ensemble
des questions qui sont débattues
aujourd'hui dans cette pré campagne on
n'est pas encore dans la campagne on est
dans la précampagne que ce soit par
exemple la question de l'immigration que
ce soit la question de la
réindustrialisation
ces deux questions posent la question
pose le problème des relations par
rapport aux réglementations européennes
d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien que
certains des candidats ou des présumés
candidats veulent organiser des
référendums sur cette question là la
question
des bas salaires eh bien ça posera la
question de l'euro et c'est peut-être un
des points les plus intéressants de
cette pré campagne est bien c'est que on
va voir surgir au travers des
propositions des uns et des autres toute
une série de problèmes qui sont des
problèmes absolument centraux de notre
relation avec l'union européenne de
notre relation avec l'euro et qu'on
verra les gens peut-être se dévoiler ou
révéler leur véritable nature à cette
occasion eh bien on verra ça arrive que
d'être en tout cas intéressant suite
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous